a
[Música]
ah
la genetista estadounidense jennifer
jones de 56 años se ha convertido en una
de las ganadoras del premio nobel de
química y también en la séptima mujer
desde 1901 en recibir este galardón
recibe este premio debido a sus
investigaciones sobre el genoma humano
que permitirán avanzar en también la
investigación sobre la lucha contra el
cáncer y terapias alternativas para su
tratamiento ella es una de las autoras
descubridoras del método conocido como
tijeras moleculares que permitirá
simplificar el genoma humano y ayudar a
tratar diferentes enfermedades genéticas
también se espera que esta semana se
anuncien los ganadores del premio nobel
de literatura de paz y de economía hasta
el momento en la mayoría de categorías
que entrega el premio nobel
estadounidenses han recibido este
galardón
[Música]
el mundo de la química está hoy de
fiesta con la entrega del premio nobel y
hubo tres proyectos muy interesantes que
quedaron simplemente como candidatos
pero que muy seguramente en el futuro
tendrán su oportunidad se trata de los
proyectos de química organometálica de
la unión y mezcla de carbono y nitrógeno
de los profesores
jon hardwicke de la universidad de
california y también del profesor
stephen burks val en la universidad de
massachusetts fue uno de los grandes
contendientes el día de hoy también la
síntesis de macro cristales con
atributos y aplicaciones en física
biología y sistemas médicos de los
profesores para wendy y quiz murray
también aquí de eeuu esto se sumó a un
proyecto de un científico japonés muy
interesante en química supramolecular
inspirada directamente en la naturaleza
pero ustedes ya saben el ganador fue el
de las tijeras moleculares
[Música]
entre los favoritos al nobel de química
de este año se ha contado el trabajo del
científico surcoreano option tecuán de
la universidad nacional de seúl junto a
dos colegas estadounidenses jon ha
destacado en la creación de
nanocristales sintéticos con unas
propiedades determinadas que pueden
emplearse en diversos terrenos un nano
cristal es en realidad una partícula
diminuta con una estructura cristalina y
en este sentido gijón ha contribuido a
la creación por ejemplo de sustancias
activas con estos nanocristales
sintéticos que un paciente puede
inocularse antes de someterse a una
resonancia magnética al entrar en
contacto con el campo magnético que
genera la máquina esta sustancia activa
ayuda a que la imagen resultante sea
mucho más nítida una imagen más nítida
del interior de nuestro cuerpo lo que
hace que el diagnóstico pueda ser mucho
más preciso éstos nanocristales
sintéticos también pueden por ejemplo
aplicarse a diversos tipos de baterías y
ayudará a mejorar así su eficiencia
energética
[Música]